des craquelures qui n'existeront bientôt
plus après le bassin de la tonne les
jardins de Versailles connaissent un
nouveau grand chantier le char d'Apollon
a quitté le domaine le 6 décembre
dernier appelons a subi les outrages du
temps et depuis trois siècles qu'il est
là les structures métalliques qui
portent les sculptures à proprement
parler qui sont en plomb ces structures
métalliques ont rouillées ce sont
affaissés et toute la sculpture
a commencé à s'affaisser il y a de très
grosses fissures dans la sculpture à
cause de cela et ce n'est pas le plomb
qui en est la cause c'est la structure
métallique à l'intérieur de chacun des
ouvrages le char a été restauré en
permanence depuis le 18e siècle mais en
surface cette fois il faudra décaper
toutes les couches de peinture sur le
dessus refaire une charpente métallique
et reformer les sculptures
ce sont des difficultés de restauration
absolument exceptionnelles que j'allais
dire depuis 300 ans personne ne sait
faire il a fallu plusieurs chantiers
successifs à Versailles entre le bassin
de la tonne aujourd'hui la restauration
des sculptures du buffet de Trianon pour
acquérir le savoir-faire permettant la
manutention de ces groupes géants des
difficultés de transport aussi chaque
élément pesant près de 5 tonnes pour une
sculpture monumentale de 30 tonnes une
restauration plus qu'attendue par les
équipes du domaine qui regardent déjà
vers le futur on est donc d'autant plus
fier de pouvoir le faire maintenant que
comme vous le savez nous préparons les
Jeux olympiques de 2024 et que pour les
épreuves d'équitation qui se dérouleront
ici et bien ce char d'Apollon redoré
flamboyant dans toute sa majesté et bien
servira
arrière-plan assez JO le char d'Apollon
trônera à nouveau au centre de la grande
perspective du domaine dans 18 mois
comme au temps du roi soleil